[Music]
what's going on guys today we're talking
about summer Bo not that kind of video
summer box office but yet if you haven't
problem with your smells try deodorant a
few months ago we all got together and
gave our predictions for the top ten
summer box office earners the results
are pretty much in let's break it down
and let's meet our crew of bold
predictors first off she is an editor at
Rotten Tomatoes you know or love her
she's a friend of the show Jacqueline
Kohli glad to be here senior editor at
Rotten Tomatoes and she's got I'll say
it the best hair in the biz great drink
thank you thank you you know this guy SJ
news new movie fights champion and
box-office predictor extraordinaire Dan
Merle hello how Dan what a summer it was
and far less disappointing than last
summer you know what you bring up a good
point what were some of the film's
quality wise that delighted you this
summer
oh well you be my neighbor was the
documentary that elevated like my entire
summer and is gonna keep me coasting
through the end of the year believing
that the world is a wonderful place I
would say sorry to bother you it's
definitely one yeah I like was you know
jazzed about at the beginning of the
year and the beginning of the summer and
it proved to be just as bonkers bat-crap
crazy as I hoped it was we made our
predictions let's take a look at our
list of 10 box-office winners and we
should note that infinity war counts and
our pool toward the star box of his
brothers mojo for example yes doesn't
count infinity war cuz it opened in
April but we counted infinity war
towards the summer cuz come on yeah come
on let's be honest if anybody is crying
foul if you're looking at the summer box
office right now and saying the meg
isn't there
oceans eight is currently number ten but
the meg is just creeping up like that
shark fin is right behind Cate Blanchett
and salmon and they're paddling but the
meg is about to catch oh yeah yeah the
meg will end up at number ten
Jacqueline Kohli the only person to put
the Meg on her list the shark came
through for me I'm
excited about that if I'm happy it's
awesome box office gray Drake also came
to play but the first purge didn't do
you any favors no it certainly didn't
we're done I guess we're done like
because maybe we're living in it right
so maybe we're just like no more movies
guys yeah you're the highest on solo
yeah ouch I
in retrospect should have been thinking
more about how angry everyone was after
force awakens I should have been
thinking about that and that everybody
just tired
cuz we need time now we need time to
heal time to recharge our blasters etc
yeah we get fatigue I need today I need
to carbo-load before I'm not so fatigued
yeah let me ask you another fatigue
question because you both had skyscraper
on your list I had a my list does
America have rock fatigue or what no I
think it was more the premise okay I
think it was the premise more than the
rock because I don't think people go to
see that movie because of the rock I
think they go see that movie because
it's just you know they wanted to see
the great the ape movie is why they go
see rampage or don't see yeah you know I
hope you're right because the minute
that I heard someone on TV like you know
and Bojack horseman they call hosts like
a Ryan Seacrest type like I don't even
have names yeah so when I heard a Ryan
Seacrest type go the next Rock Buster to
come out and I was owned oh he's over
let's go go over to a Dan's list here's
a movie that did not deliver the
box-office goods Mamma Mia yeah it was
up there it was up there hot and honest
but it fell prey to you know some of
those August sleepers that we talked
about here was the surprise for me I
didn't really like the first Mamma Mia
movie yeah I really liked this one like
yes yes well it's made of meter bears
you're out on that one too like it
actually was higher so I think you're
not the only one that thought that
another one that did not quite perform
as a couple of us hoped oceans eight
still did well though
I mean I think what the next four movies
maybe all did like a hundred million
dollars this is not this is a very good
year I mean in all honesty I think they
said it was up what another 16 percent
from last year or something ridiculous
like yeah so let me ask you guys that's
really interesting to me do we owe that
to the quality of movies do we owe that
like what do we base better box office
this summer on the way house would tell
you it's them
I mean movie pass AMC that there has
been an advent of these movie plans does
that have anything to do with it totally
does I think especially when we talk
about the fact that this is box office
dollars and the markets that we found
out that movie pass and a lot of these
streaming subscriptions were heavy were
New York and LA where folks are spending
fifteen twenty dollars a ticket you know
so I think that has something to do with
it and I don't think there was a move
I'm trying to think of like a
blockbuster movie that was universally
hated yeah you know even solo wasn't
that so much loved it or hated kind of
thing I don't think drastic world was
that way I feel like the did a lot of
the movies like we're either like really
good or okay yeah it was a whelmed
box-office we were not over we were not
under yes well I like that I love that
Jacqueline I might I might borrow that
and use that sometimes let's take a look
at my list
what happened Christopher Robin it's
like you dropped me off in the Hundred
Acre Wood and left me for dead that's a
very your way of looking at it had good
legs it had a great multiple I just
didn't open Hugh yeah yeah we got lost
in the shuffle yeah you know one of us
all crazy rotation no you keep pointing
that out none of us saw that movie yes
why that's good so myself for this
yeah you know that crazy rotations none
of us saw coming you will be so mad
about that Jacqueline yeah didn't I
trust your gut I didn't let my words
like translate to my to my picks do you
think the fine performance of crazy
rotations at the box office will bring
us more inclusion more diversity in
casts and yes are all the wrong reasons
yeah
and from a box-office standpoint kind of
looking at what crazy rich Asians did
you saw the hold that it had and also
because there's so much enthusiasm about
it amongst the asian-american community
it created a buzz and then in week two
if you look at the people that went out
to the box office to see it it was
everybody that had heard about how good
it was from the base that had energized
in its first weekend that went to see it
the second weekend across the spectrum
demographically so if I were studio the
lesson I would take away from it is that
if you make projects that reflect the
diversity that this country has that's
buzz that's marketing people get excited
and then if you deliver a good movie
then that kind of transcends and the
movie can grow and spread and and and
make 150 million dollars off of a thirty
million dollar budget like crazy rich
Asians did yeah I know cuz I mean what I
picture is like you know the guy with a
cigar and he's like Asians are hot
alright so let us reveal the results you
guys oh my god all right tied for last
place with seven box office predictions
correct this guy and gray Drake Dan and
Jacqueline both had eight so round of
applause but then we go to the tiebreak
which was having your films placed in
the correct order and drumroll please
Dan Merle takes it Wow oh eight eight to
seven that's the with a tiebreaker I
think we all won the winner has to say
as long as he's classy yeah classy
yeah this was such a weird weird in the
sense of like I said no highs and lows
no no you know you know you always
expect some kind of volatility and I
think for all of us there were seven
movies that were pretty much a lock and
there were no surprises there so it was
really just a roll of the dice I'd like
to see the surprise stories the things
like crazy rotations that's what makes
it fun to do this game it's like what
are the ones you overthrow a traditional
movie
yeah times it's an underdog that yeah
now that you put it that way it makes me
realize that this is exactly what
Hollywood wants that's why they make all
these sequels that's why they rely on
this IP in the way that they do because
they they all they're number crunchers
know that they will be a certain amount
of successful if this is what they keep
making so it kind of gives me goosebumps
like go support something small those
supporters crazy rich Asians that's sort
of a movie that comes out of nowhere
mm-hmm so what was your favorite movie
of the summer what was your least
favorite disappointed by anything let us
know in the comments below we want to
know I want to thank this awesome group
of box-office minds plenty of box office
but no Bo today y'all smell great
Jacqueline Coley Gray Drake Dan Merle
thanks guys Dan Congrats
thank you for watching screen junkies
we'll see you next time bye bye